a robot designed to scratch your itch oh
and here's a palm laser so that you can
be like Iron Man Vsauce Kevin here this
is my flow a multi touch LCD wall was
rigged to play fleet commander a
real-time strategy game developed at the
Electronic visualization laboratory it's
a Star Wars game and watching these kids
plant reminds me of Ender's Game
watching this tetris master reminds me
never to think I'm good at Tetris again
and watching this might make you barf
it's the steepest rollercoaster in the
world it's located in Japan and has a 43
meter drop with a 121 degree freefall
to cool off after the ride visit the
Japanese frozen aquarium it showcases
450 specimens of marine life frozen in
ice and illuminated with blue light hey
I'm wearing an episode of The Simpsons
you certainly are sir you certainly are
the world's largest photo is on display
at the Culver Center of the Arts the 32
by 111 foot photo was taken with the
world's largest camera which is an
abandoned aircraft hangar with a 6
millimeter hole in the side that
functions as the aperture perhaps the
most complicated way to take a photo is
with this Rube Goldberg machine it took
about six months to put together but the
results are well worth it check it out
after all that work relax in the hammock
house
it's a five-story hangout spot in Vienna
meant to serve as an oasis of relaxation
and outside of it is this here's some
levitating water it's not a video effect
this real steady stream of water has a
strobe effect on it to make it look like
individual floating droplets and this is
the flash
phase distortion effect the pictures of
these women are not altered in any way
but if you stare at the cross in the
middle as the faces flash their images
appear to stretch and distort in a
freakish manner
finally an epic animation referred to as
Little Nemo from exactly 100 years ago
I'm gonna leave you with a riddle some
cobs are ticks all ticks are bonds some
bonds are paps some abs are Tings
therefore cogs are definitely PABs true
or false and why there are two animation
and three video game references in this
video the first person to name them all
will be our genius of the week so good
luck and as always thanks for watching
it was all a dream I just read Harper's
Magazine Babe Ruth and Charlie see up in
the model team and get purchased on my
wall
every Sunday Matt name down at Carnegie
Hall I played my florida friend till it
broke in half
[Music]